hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching ghosts for the very
first time all I know about this movie
is the pottery scene and I think that's
if you haven't seen it which everyone
has but if you have it like me if you
have it I think the only thing you
probably know about the movie is the
pottery scene I tried to make I'm
clearly trying to have like a Demi Moore
moment here and I have this modeling
magic not an ADD and I while watching
the movie was making this and especially
if you turn it over this way it just
looks like you know yikes
do I know Patrick Swayze from anything
else other than ghosts seeing the
reference photos on the DVD that I have
I don't think I have I haven't seen
Dirty Dancing that's the only thing I
know he was in as well I don't think
I've ever seen Patrick Swayze in
anything let's see if he can persuade
see me too like this okay well I've
already done enough damage to this video
already so let's just get into it
[Music]
[Laughter]
what that was so much different but I
was imagining this it was gonna be this
romantic
sad and it wasn't why is that the scene
that everyone thinks of when they think
about this movie it's not even it's not
even like a big pivotal point it's it's
sweet what the hell help fire demons
dragging people to hell and he Patrick
Swayze Samms he went into Whoopi
Goldberg and then Oh was gonna have clay
sex with with Demi Lovato Demi Moore I'm
so perplexed a lot about this movie
surprised me and Confused me but confuse
me in a good way so I was like expecting
him to die shirts called
ghosts I knew that much that much I knew
so I was looking out for his death scene
and that was just such a confusing shot
when he like awoke and he was the ghost
and then he was laying there dead and
that you know CGI isn't amazing but it
gets the point across it didn't take me
out of it at all it was very 1990s the
whole movie had a lot of like this is a
1990s film vibe going on but I still
think for the most part it held up
pretty damn well
there are also some like scary moments
too okay we're just I'm getting ahead of
myself
let's get into it Sam and Molly are
living together they're renovating this
old house and she's an artist and he's a
banker and they make it work so now
there's some pretty cool shots not only
going into showing you this cool place -
they're renovating they have this old
antique here and the guy who's moving it
like sweeps it across and you see it in
that shot of like what seems like that
was super cool and engaging we meet
Sam's friend Chad Karl who I had a bad
vibe from from the variant the from the
get-go let's
be honest he's in an elevator coughing
on everyone around him saying that he
has a very contagious
sickness and that's rude and gross yeah
nasty Karl get nasty and the clay
pottery scene happens and I just wrote
clay pottery scene I I want to have clay
sex which honestly with what I've made
here this monstrosity I probably could
such a high Sam and Molly go to see a
show Macbeth and he fell asleep in it I
guess and then she starts talking about
her art and how she's nervous about
putting it in some bigger galleries and
he's like it shouldn't matter what other
people think it should matter only what
I think
well that chick fine that could be a
nice sentiment if it comes from the
right place which I do think it does but
it just such 90s writings that's not how
art works you wouldn't say that if you
were a plumber if he does a shit job and
he's like worried about it and his wife
is like it doesn't matter what they
think about it only matters that doesn't
that's not a that okay so you get it and
then he gets shot and like I said I was
expecting the death to happen but then
he gets up and I was like oh I guess
they're just toying with us now that's
rude and he's not actually dead but he
was actually dead it was a very
confusing shot and I think totally meant
it to be that way it was really cool he
goes back to his house and the guy who
killed him is in his home rightfully so
Sam follows the criminal on to a train
follows him home
but on the train this really under your
skin creepy sequence happens with this
guy who lives on the train but he's a
ghost
he is able to break physical things
whereas everything is like you go
through it walk through wall you know
what I'm saying and he like breaks a
glass window and as I get off my train
after he says two words that should not
be creepy but they were very creepy when
he said it he's like like drains so
creepy I wasn't expecting to get like
weirded out by this film at all oh my
god if I could passed away and then
started haunting me I would love that
then we meet Whoopi Goldberg's character
and her name is Oda Mae brown and I love
her character so much she's this fake
flop of a spiritual medium I okay here's
a little background on me and what I
believe in I love the idea of ghosts and
spirits and I am sad to say that I
definitely believe in them and I also do
not at all believe in mediums
just pigments using the otherworldly
entities that I believe in entities that
the word I'm looking for so much
caffeine I love that they made her a con
artist though and then she's able to
actually hear Sam and so she helps him
this like con artist medium is actually
able to hear this ghost and help him and
it's a really funny premise so he
convinces her to talk to Molly try to
help her he finds out that his friend
Carl the one who was talking about
sickness in an elevator yet is the one
who killed him which is pretty helpless
cuz he can't touch anything and you
can't do anything about it and that
freaking sucks he's got this line her
car was driving away it was just like I
had a life man I had a life and it's
super sad
can't you imagine that peace that Wow
so Oda Mae brown helps him out by giving
this money the Karl was stealing and
then they they give it to Catholic
Charities give it to another charity
good board she says gasps I get a little
gas from time to time that's all gasps
Oda Mae brown and also a direct quote
from my gassy cat like at this point
everyone knows - there's ghosts Oda Mae
brown is now a real medium and all the
ghosts are going to her and Molyneux's
and Carl knows and Carl's being beaten
up and and there's just a lot of ghost
knowledge and it's a very well time to
be alive for ghosts Sam goes in - OH -
Mae's body and and like it's getting
real romantic with Molly and I just
wrote are they gonna have clay sex or
not and no no Carl ruins the moment
though he's the worst there's a fight
scene with a ghost amazing just really
not where I was expecting this movie to
go I guess I should have known but I
didn't clearly hello
I'm Tamara didn't understand the basic
premise of a classic film hi how are you
Sam
dies a very glassy death and then gets
drugged down to hell by Gary Helghast
the healthy stir-fry ting and it's
mostly the sound effects that they have
with them pretty menacing Ben Sam is
going to heaven and and some some reason
Molly can see him now
and so they kissed and it's really sweet
I was definitely crying you'll sing
along with the main song of the movie
hey decent movie that you'll enjoy the
story and probably need Kleenex nearby
for the ending will be won an Oscar for
her performance the twist is especially
true
uh yeah whoopee was amazing I'm glad to
hear that she won an Oscar for this
because she was really funny really good
I didn't feel like the twist was I don't
know I the twist of it not being like a
massive chick flick was definitely
twisty but I guess I guess I would have
real it I don't know he seems kind of
evil he was talking about getting people
diseases in an elevator so I feel like
he was kind of oh he's totally the
villain will be the first thing you
think when you see the dude who's
totally the villain that's more how I
had a bad feeling about him so it was
less twisty and more like he makes me
uncomfortable no people want to believe
in ghosts just so you can follow the
blip it's the only option for me
the pottery scene will be a surprising
turn on it was surprising and it was a
turn-on yes you'll want to recreate the
pottery scene well I didn't love that I
honestly it looks better this way so
it's just it's the color of it that
really is not great we're gonna get I
this wouldn't really surprise me in a
way that I I just wasn't expecting what
it was it was scarier than I thought it
was gonna be it was definitely a more I
guess complex story than I thought I was
gonna I thought it was gonna be just a
nothing romantic film which is stupid
for me to think that because this is a
classic that people talk about and
reference and parody all the time and I
don't know why I continuously do this
I'm like I'm just not gonna like it I'm
not gonna watch it oh babe thank you for
watching I will see you all next week
I
[Music]
you
[Applause]